nous reprenons la séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi relatif aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
et portant diverses autres dispositions
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
vulter rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidentes
comme mission Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
arrivons au terme de l'examen du projet
de loi relatif aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 je salue mais que
les rapporteurs Madame Christine labour
pour la commission des affaires sociales
madame Béatrice Bel-Ami ainsi que
messieurs bertrandsor et ses vanne Mazar
pour les affaires culturelles
les échanges approfondis constructifs
que nous avons vu avec le Sénat au cours
des dernières semaines nous ont permis
d'aboutir au texte adoptés par la
commission misseuse paritaire mardi
dernier le texte de la CMP et le fruit
d'un compromis je considère qu'il
respecte les grands équilibres du projet
de loi initiale sur l'essentiel des
articles nous avons conservé les
rédactions issues de l'Assemblée
nationale à la suite des ajouts opérés
par le Sénat tous les ions leurs
dizaines d'amendements issus des groupes
de position étaient adoptés lors de
l'examen l'assemblée notamment sur
l'article 7 ce qui démontre toute la
richesse du travail parlementaire
au-delà des réflexes partisans des
discussions avec nos collègues sénateurs
ont principalement porté sur deux
articles
tout d'abord l'article 7 relatif à
l'expérimentation de la vidéoprotection
intelligente soulevait une double
difficulté d'une part le terme de
l'expérimentation il était fixé au 30
juin 2025 à lessive l'examen au Sénat
puis ramener au 31 décembre 2024 par
notre assemblée d'autre part la durée
des conservations des données
d'entraînement des algorithmes le Sénat
avait plafonné cette durée selon les
règles en vigueur du droit commun soit
30 jours pour les caméras de
vidéoprotection et 7 jours pour les
caméras aéroportées et nous avions
envisagé une durée maximale identique à
la durée de l'expérimentation le texte
issu de la CMP parvient à un point
d'équilibre la date finale de
l'expérimentation est fixée au 31 mars
2025 et la durée maximale de
conservation des données d'entraînement
s'élèvera à 12 mois ce qui garantira la
pleine opérationnalité du dispositif
je tiens à rappeler que la date du 30
juin 2025 voté par le Sénat
correspondait à une préconisation émise
par le Conseil d'État
le compromis trouvé doit donc se dire à
l'aune d'un calendrier pratique les
premiers traitements algorithmiques ne
sont pas déployés sur le terrain avant
la fin de l'automne 2023 compte tenu des
échéances administratives préalables il
est donc indispensable de prévoir un
allongement dérogatoire de la durée de
conservation des images de
vidéoprotection uniquement à des fins
d'apprentissage et d'algorithmes je
pense ici aux images qui seront captées
lors de la peau au coupe du monde de
rugby en septembre-octobre 2023 et qui
pourront être utilisés selon les
conditions bien sûr très strictes pour
garantir la mise au point des
algorithmes d'ici des jeux organisés à
l'été 2024 dans les faits
l'expérimentation se guidera se
déroulera sur une période de 18 mois
tout au plus 18 mois c'est la c'est une
durée trois fois inférieure à celle de
l'expérimentation des données
automatisées du traitement automatisé
des données de connexion mise en place
en matière de renseignement par la loi
de 2015
nous inscrivons ainsi dans le cadre
prévu par l'article 37-1 de la
Constitution il nous reviendra en tant
que législateur de faire le bilan de
cette expérimentation au premier
trimestre 2025 à la lumière du rapport
d'évaluation qui sera rendu public le 31
décembre 2024
l'anticipons pas aujourd'hui les débats
que nous aurons dans deux ans ou plutôt
assumons ces débats pour ceux qui sont
pour les uns un rejet de principe des
outils de l'intelligence artificielle
dans un préservation de la sécurité de
nos concitoyens pour les autres dont je
suis assis qu'une large parle de cette
assemblée l'intérêt d'un usage régulier
encadré sécurisé de ces technologies
pour rendre plus efficace l'action des
services de sécurité
je maintiens qu'il fera vite passer dans
la pratique à des lois techniques sur le
modèle des lois bioéthiques pour
débattre sereinement de ces sujets et en
faire apparaître l'importance à nos
concitoyens je crois que le travail de
nos deux assemblées renforçant au cours
de la même de la CNP les outils de
protection des libertés individuelles
constituent un travail remarquable
j'espère qu'il pourra nourrir les débats
en cours dans l'écriture de la directive
européenne sur l'intelligence
artificielle et sera considéré comme
exemplaire nous avons ensuite longuement
discuté de l'article 18 qui prévoit
expérimentale l'attribution de nouvelles
licences de taxi en ville de développer
les transports de personnes en fauteuil
roulant en Île-de-France le projet de
loyer initial prévoyait un seuil de
délicence face à l'urgence de la
situation l'objectif était clair cibler
prioritairement les entités économiques
ayant la capacité d'investir et
d'acquérir pour que ces véhicules soient
disponibles à temps pour les jeux j'ai
été pour autant sensible aux arguments
du Sénat qui craignaient qu'un seuil
trop subjectif puisse entra créer un
risque d'inconstitutionnalité nous avons
donc supprimer ce seuil tout en
encadrant et en précisant les critères
d'attribution des nouvelles licences je
ne reviendrai pas en détail sur les
autres aspects du texte suscité un
accord rapide avec le Sénat qu'il
s'agisse des dispositifs de soins de la
lutte anti-dopage ou de la sécurité dans
les stades le texte soumis à nos débats
et respectueux de les volontés de chaque
chambre il poursuit l'objectif j'espère
partager de faire de cet événement
majeur une réussite pour notre pays je
vous invite donc à le soutenir je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Madame Amélie ou des
accastéra ministre des Sports et des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis heureuse
de me présenter à nouveau devant vous à
l'occasion de ce vote sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire dont je tiens à saluer la
réussite à l'issue d'un véritable
travail d'enrichissement du texte de la
part des deux assemblées et de nombreux
groupes parlementaires au cours de nos
échanges de nos débats d'abord au Sénat
puis au sein de cette hémicycle je crois
que nous avons su convaincre sur les
différents sujets qui pouvaient susciter
des doutes je pense en particulier au
disposition relatives au renforcement de
notre édifice antidopage mais aussi
tenir compte de vos observations de vos
propositions pour améliorer ensemble ce
texte chaque fois que nécessaire y
compris sur des mesures très concrètes
ou qui resteront après les jeux je pense
par exemple à la mobilisation des
vétérinaires lors des compétitions
olympiques et paralympiques la meilleure
articulations entre interdiction
judiciaire et administrative de stade et
les précisions apportées au régime de
pointage associés pour mieux lutter
contre les violences et les incivilités
dans nos stades la possibilité également
de signes distinctifs pour mieux repérer
les taxis accessibles le texte issu des
travaux parlementaires remplis ainsi les
objectifs que nous nous étions
collectivement fixés au début de son
examen il demeure concis moins de 30
articles centré sur des mesures
indispensables entièrement tournés vers
le déploiement opérationnel des jeux
pour en réunir les conditions de
réussite dans le respect plein et entier
des droits et libertés de nos
concitoyens le texte proposé par la CMP
nous permettra de couvrir l'ensemble de
nos besoins sans renoncer à nos
exigences une polyclinique et des
professionnels de santé
au service des athlètes et des
délégations sans prélever sur des moyens
existants ni peser sur notre offre de
soins un élan nouveau donné à la
formation au gestes qui sauvent pour
développer chez nos concitoyens le sens
de l'engagement et du premier secours
une lutte contre le dopage qui va
pouvoir rester à l'avant-garde mondial
conformément à nos engagements
internationaux et qui laissera en
héritage sur l'ensemble du territoire un
édifice solide sur le plan des contrôles
des techniques d'analyse et du partage
de l'information la navette
parlementaire a également permis
l'amélioration significative de nos
outils de sécurisation et de
coordination des moyens à l'occasion des
grands événements sportifs je salue à ce
titre le cadre renforcé du traitement
par algorithme des images dont les
conditions d'emploi font désormais
l'objet de très nombreuses garanties
d'un contrôle permanent de la CNIL
assurant de bout en bout le respect des
droits et libertés avec avec une date
d'échéance désormais fixée au 31 mars
2025 s'agissant la lutte contre les
violences et incivilités je veux saluer
la porte par le Parlement d'un axe
également dédié à la prévention au
travers d'une billetterie sécurisée et
modernisée ainsi que les ajustements
apportés aux mesures d'interdiction de
stade que je mentionnais par un
caractère proportionné sur le plan des
transports la CMP a permis d'ultime
amélioration pour garantir la sécurité
juridique du déploiement d'ici l'année
prochaine de près de 800 licences
supplémentaires de taxis accessibles
dans le ressort de la préfecture de
police enfin pour que ces jeux soient
au-delà de Paris et de la
Seine-Saint-Denis ce véritablement de la
France entière nous avons désormais tous
les outils pour les faire vivre dans nos
territoires en permettant l'activité
commerciale le dimanche sur certains
sites autour des zones de compétition
désormais circonscrites dans sa période
du 15 juin au en septembre 2024 ainsi
que des animations festives autour du
relais de la flamme et des différents
sites de compétition de façon plus
globale je me réjouis que ce texte porte
en son sein les principaux marqueurs
emblématiques des jeux de paris 2024 qui
sont autant d'exigence que nous œuvrons
pour promouvoir au cœur de notre modèle
sportif je pense notamment à l'impératif
d'accessibilité des sites comme des
transports au service d'un regard
nouveau porté sur le handicap dont vous
avez fait progresser la prise en compte
dans ce texte ainsi que des engagements
forts en termes de responsabilité
environnementale et notamment de
mobilité durable au terme de ce cycle
parlementaire de près de deux mois et
demi je voudrais très sincèrement vous
dire le plaisir que j'ai eu avoir ces
débats avec vous dans la qualité reflète
l'esprit de responsabilité qui n'a je
crois cessé de les animer et qui
démontre que lorsqu'il s'agit de faire
réussir de faire gagner la France en en
disant impeccablement le premier
événement sportif planétaire il naît de
clivage partisans qui ne saurait être
surmontée dès l'adoption je le souhaite
et la promulgation de cette loi en
particulier avec mes collègues Gérald
Darmanin François Brown et Clément
Beaune nous mettrons tout en œuvre pour
en assurer l'application rapide afin de
tenir les engagements pris devant vous
nous avons déjà commencé à préparer
cette importante travail réglementaire
il nous attend et nous aurons à cœur de
le conduire avec précision et agilité je
reste bien entendu à la disposition de
la représentation nationale pour vous
tenir informé des prochaines étapes de
notre préparation
opérationnelle en lien avec la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation en lien avec le groupe de
travail chargé du suivi de la
préparation des jeux et de la mission
d'information sur les retombées
économiques et sociales de ces jeux mais
également au-delà de l'avancement des
nombreux projets que nous portons au
bénéfice
du développement de la pratique sportive
de tous les Français je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre attention et de votre
confiance
merci Madame la Ministre
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise une motion de rejet préalable
déposée en application de l'article 91
alinéa 5 du règlement la parole est donc
à Madame Elisa Martin
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente nous sommes
donc au terme de l'examen de la loi
autre disposition et Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à ce propos par olympique
forcée de constater que pour les
personnes porteuses de handicap le
contenu est pas d'ailleurs les
associations s'expriment très fortement
en ce sens déjà olympiques et
paralympiques non accessibles il fallait
oser vous l'avez fait à notre corps
défendant d'ailleurs puisque nous avons
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
le groupe et les filles nues qui n'ont
même pas été examinés au motif de
l'article 45 10 ans que ces amendements
ne faisaient pas référence à la loi qui
pourtant devait bien traiter de du
caractère paralympique des jeux je vais
si vous le voulez bien commencer par un
petit jeu de devinette
quel pays est visé par le rapporteur
spécial des Nations Unies et le
Commissaire aux Droits de l'Homme du
Conseil européen pour menace sur
l'expression Pacifique d'opinion ou
usage excessif de la force quel pays est
visé par ses propres avocats qui parlent
d'une dérive inacceptable digne d'un
pays autoritaire quel pays est dénoncé
par l'usage de la technique de la nasse
dangereuse et liberticide quel pays est
visé par un syndicat de journaliste qui
dénonce les consignes des rédactions qui
interdisent l'usage des mots violence
policière
idem d'ailleurs pour une société de
journalistes d'une chaîne publique il en
existe encore quel pays a osé classé
sans suite une pétition signée quasiment
en quelques pour dissoudre une forme de
police motorisée violente et effrayante
quel pays remet en cause la liberté
d'associations et menace les défenseurs
historiques des droits humains la Chine
la Corée la Russie et bien non notre
pays la France mais cela ne suffisait
pas les Jeux Olympiques permettent d'en
ajouter encore et encore pour construire
une société
liberticide sécuritaire ou l'autre est
un danger potentiel j'en veux pour
preuve scanner corporel à onde
millimétrique en quête administrative de
sécurité qui vise un nombre de personnes
équivalent au nombre d'habitants de la
ville de Paris bien sûr on y est habitué
sans surenchère pénal
inutile et bien sûr la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique
multiplication à l'infini des regards
inquisiteurs et normatifs et normatif
criminalisation d'un certain nombre de
comportements ceux des plus précaires et
des militants en particulier ceux qui
voudraient critiquer les Jeux Olympiques
dans leur dimension consumériste ou bien
écocide savent à quoi aujourd'hui se
tenir tout ça nous l'avons dit répéter
argumenter avec bien souvent peu ou pas
de réponse de la part du gouvernement et
du ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin en particulier le fait nouveau
aujourd'hui et qui explique notre motion
de rejet donc le fait nouveau et le
résultat de la commission mixte
paritaire le peuple que le gouvernement
avait concédé d'une main a été repris à
l'aigrement de l'autre je m'explique et
déroule ce jeu malsain tout d'abord le
travail dimanche déjà vivement critiqué
par les groupes de la nuque par son
extension dans le temps et dans l'espace
ces vues ajouter 15 jours de
possibilités pourquoi personne ne le
sait ce que nous devons montrer du pays
la France c'est la France des acquis
sociaux c'est la France de la culture
c'est la France du patrimoine qui n'a
pas besoin d'ouverture de magasins
d'enseignes ou autres boutiques de là à
penser qu'il s'agit d'un ballon d'essai
il n'y a qu'un pas que nous franchissons
allègrement de la même façon que les
salariés acquis cela sera imposé voici
ensuite voilà ensuite l'enjeu de la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles sommes-nous hors-jeu
sommes-nous hors sujet et bien non pas
du tout puisque ce que l'on constate
c'est que pendant les manifestations
sportives ce type de violence augmente
commandement de repli en amendement de
repli ce que nous avions pu obtenir dans
l'hémicycle était une campagne par voie
d'affichage une campagne par voie
d'affichage la belle affaire et bien
cette campagne d'affichage a été
purement et simplement supprimé en
commission mixte paritaire franchement
toutes les couvertures de magazines quel
qu'il soit ne règleront rien à cette
affaire voilà comment a été traité ce
sujet considéré comme première cause
nationale par ce gouvernement
des miettes ont été remises en cause
lors de cette CMP nous y voyons pour ce
qui nous concerne la marche des lobbies
industriels autre chose autre chose la
suppression de l'arrêter préfectorale
qui fixera la zone dans laquelle la
vidéo surveillance algorithmique sera
mise en oeuvre empêchera tout recours
contre celle-ci c'est malin c'est malin
nous le reconnaissons mais
particulièrement anti républicain et
particulièrement liberticide ce qui est
la même chose enfin ce n'est pas
seulement des entreprises européennes ou
françaises qui pourraient être amenés à
utiliser toutes ces données
issues des dispositifs de
vidéosurveillance quel qu'il soit mais
des entreprises dites conformes
seulement je veux redire ce que dit la
loi sur l'utilisation de ces dispositifs
il s'appliqueront c'est ce que dit la
loi aux manifestations sportives
culturelles récréatives par leur ampleur
et leur circonstances sont
particulièrement exposées à des risques
d'acte de terrorisme ou d'atteinte à la
sécurité des personnes autant dire qu'a
peu de choses près toute manifestation
pourra être concernée conclusion pas de
prise en compte réel des personnes
porteuses de handicap augmentation du
travail du dimanche réallongement du
temps contre la vie des députés de cette
période d'expérimentation aucune
priorité donnée aux entreprises
françaises ou européennes aucune
protection des données personnelles que
cela va permettre de brasser est-ce cela
que vous voulez est-ce cela l'intérêt de
cette loi je veux dire en conclusion en
mon nom et au nom bien sûr de mon groupe
elle est fi Nupe pour celles et ceux qui
se préoccupent de la sécurité des
publics des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques via ces dispositifs
technologiques mesdames et messieurs les
députés pensez-vous sincèrement
après cette commission mix paritaire que
cette loi réponde à ses objectifs
initiaux merci
merci madame Martin
et la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur
Elisa Martin nous avons une très
nombreux débat mais je ne croyais pas
tout à l'heure en parlant grosso modo
des postures les uns des autres que vous
me donneriez le loisir d'une telle
caricature parce que en réalité vous ne
parlez pas des Jeux Olympiques si jamais
vous n'arrivez pas à comprendre que ces
jeux vont être à un moment donné non
seulement une non seulement chers
collègues ici que c'est juste vont être
non seulement une occasion fantastique
de rayonnement notre pays mais aussi une
cible pour tous ceux qui voudraient lui
nuire c'est que vous n'avez pas compris
ce qui va se passer et évidemment les
outils que nous mettons en oeuvre sont
là pour garantir la liberté de ceux qui
voudront y assister mais aussi leur
sécurité mais non
en l'espèce vous n'avez même pas dans
l'exercice pourtant qu'il devrait
commencer commun à beaucoup d'entre vous
de cettempp vous n'avez pas noté qu'il y
avait une amélioration même par rapport
au texte de l'Assemblée sur la
préservation des données qui seront
justement limitées de façon à pouvoir
faire en sorte qu'il y a un usage
proportionné des proportions des de ces
algorithmes qui nous seront là que pour
aider à l'analyse des données d'analyser
son image alors vous pourrez faire
référence au goéland monsieur Bernay
verdalissi vous les avez bien aimé cela
mais en réalité c'est ce texte est
équilibré qu'il pourra en effet inspirer
l'Union européenne dans la réalité dans
le dans la rédaction du réglementation
qui a bien ressortir sur l'intelligence
artificielle et que je le crois il
permettra en effet de garantir et la
liberté et la sécurité de tous ceux qui
vont qui voudront participer à cette
fête je vous remercie je vous avais pas
évidemment à rejeter cette émotion de
rejet
merci monsieur le rapporteur je suis
saisie par les groupes d'explications de
vote la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Pradal pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente je crois
qu'il faut pas se payer de mots cette
motion j'ai préalable en fait a pour but
de rendre plus compliqué l'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques présentent trois
types de risques le premier risque est
un risque que nous n'ayons pas toutes
les avancées voulues pour l'organisation
de ces Jeux Olympiques que ce soit en
matière de mobilité que ce soit en
matière de santé ça a été rappelé par le
rapporteur que je remercie le second
point est en matière de sécurité il nous
faut sécuriser ses jeux qui sont un
enjeu important pour notre pays et pour
l'organisation sportive internationale
les avancées qui sont prévues sont
indispensables pour que les jeux se
déroulent bien voter cette motion de
rejet préalable ne permettrait pas ses
avancées et enfin troisième risque c'est
de se priver de l'opportunité
extraordinaire que donne à chaque fois
ces grands événements sportifs de tester
d'expérimenter de progresser pour un
pays il y a 100 ans nous avons eu les
Jeux Olympiques il a fallu entendre un
siècle pour les avoir à nouveau ne
gâchons pas cette opportunité et en
ayant une vue à court terme et en votant
cette motion de rejet préalable nous
nous priverions de la possibilité de
faire des progrès sur les domaines que
j'ai évoqués c'est pour cela que le
groupe Horizon est apparenté avec
énergie votre acompte cette motion
projet préalable merci
je vous remercie
et la parole est à Madame Sandra rogol
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur qu'il
y avait eu des amendements des
oppositions intégrées à ce texte qu'il y
avait eu la possibilité d'un dialogue
alors oui nous avons pu parler dialoguer
ce serait peut-être un peu excessif
puisque
jusqu'à la CMP nos amendements sont
tombés petit à petit donc peut-être que
par opposition vous parlez des
républicains ça m'aurait échappé le
souci même si j'en plaisante c'est que
ce texte ne porte pas à plaisanter
études après étude les reculons étaient
de plus en plus nombreux jusqu'à la CMP
qui fait même voler le consensus qu'il y
avait dans cette hémicycle pour ne pas
porter jusqu'à 2025 la préservation des
des
dispositions de l'article 7 qui est un
sort donc une vidéo surveillance
algorithmique à savoir de la
reconnaissance biométrique partout plus
que ça sur cet article 7 on en revient à
plus aucun lien entre les Jeux
Olympiques paralympique et
l'installation de ces caméras ce n'est
donc plus du tout une expérimentation
enfin si c'est l'expérimentation de
dispositif qui n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde tant il met en
question nos libertés fondamentales nos
libertés individuelles et nos libertés
collectives on aurait pu arriver à une
discussion n'aurait peut-être pu
échanger mais étape après étape vous
êtes appuyé c'est un choix politique et
après tous les rendre en face doivent en
être ravis sur la droite et l'extrême
droite pour faire passer ce texte quoi
qu'il en coûte il en coûte aujourd'hui
la mise en cause la mise en danger de
nos libertés
comme seule la Chine à oser faire pire
puisque seule la Chine a osé faire pire
pardon à ce jour avec son permis à point
social qui je le rappelle je le répète
et permis par les dispositifs mis en
place à partir de 2008 et des Jeux
Olympiques nous voterons donc pour cette
motion de rejet préalable je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine oui merci madame la
Présidente on l'a dit enfin j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises dans ces débats nous nous
pensons qu'il y avait un qui doit être
il était possible d'avoir un chemin
consensuel de Concorde pour une loi
olympique une deuxième loi olympique
pour que notre pays soit réunis pour
accueillir au mieux et dans les
meilleures conditions les Jeux
Olympiques ce qui j'en doute pas et le
souci de tout le monde ici dans cette
hémicycle mais au lieu de choisir une la
voix d'un consensus et de la Concorde
vous avez introduit dans cette loi un
certain nombre de d'éléments qui étaient
des éléments de discorde et qui était
surtout des éléments qui visaient à
pérenniser dans le temps des
expérimentations qui n'avaient pas leur
place et qui n'était pas nécessaire pour
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques donc
je rejoins de préoccupation qui ont été
exprimées tout à l'heure par ma collègue
Elisa Martin mais pour autant et je l'ai
dit en première lecture je le redis ici
après la CMP pour autant nous nous
voterons pas cette motion de rejet et
nous nous abstiendrons sur la loi parce
que nous pensons qu'il faut à tout prix
se donner les moyens de bien accueillir
et de bien organiser les Jeux même si
nous regrettons que le chemin du
consensus est pas été suivi de bout en
bout par le gouvernement et la majorité
ça aurait été possible en évitant
quelques articles
la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre chers collègue le
groupe liote ne soutiendra pas non plus
cette motion de rejet
certes le texte n'est pas parfait il y a
des regrets mais il a été travaillé il a
été amendé et surtout je crois que par
rapport à l'enjeu il nous faut être
responsable ces jeux doivent être une
réussite pour la France et cet outil va
quand même permettre de faire ce travail
que l'on doit à la fois notre pays et à
notre image merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Thomas rodigos pour le groupe
Renaissance merci merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le rapporteur je tiens à saluer le
travail qui a fait monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur vuittet avec Madame
canaillère rapporteur pour le Sénat on
est arrivé comme l'a dit monsieur le
rapporteur à un texte d'équilibre après
cette commission mixte paritaire un
grand nombre des avancées que nous avons
porté en commission des lois de la
semaine nationale et ensuite dans
l'hémicycle ont été conservés je pense
notamment aux images génériques pour les
scanners millimétriques je pense à
l'amendement de notre collègue Stella
Dupont pour pouvoir embaucher des
étudiants étrangers dans les agences de
sécurité qui travailleront parce que
nous avons un besoin très important je
pense aussi sur les taxis puisque nous
avions indifférent avec le Sénat pour
que nous ayons vraiment 1600
supplémentaires pour des taxis qui sont
vraiment
pour les personnes en fauteuil roulant
donc je pense que nous sommes dans un
bon texte je regrette cette motion de
rejet elle montre finalement la vérité
sur la France insoumise d'ailleurs
Daniel simonel avait dit très clairement
lorsqu'elle avait défendu un amendement
elle avait dit avec beaucoup d'honnêteté
qu'elle était contre cet événement donc
je pense que la France insoumise vous
devriez assumer le fait que vous êtes
contre l'organisation de ce grand de ces
grands événements comment voudriez-vous
que nous organisations nous organisions
des événements de cette ampleur sans des
moyens de sécurité comme nous allons le
prévoir avec ce texte de loi nous allons
accueillir plus de 100000 athlètes nous
allons accueillir des millions de
personnes de visiteurs et vous voudriez
que nous accueillons avec des vieilles
des vieux mode de sécurité nous avons
besoin de cette expérimentation de la
vidéoprotection intelligente cela se
fait déjà dans certains pays
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu dire
donc nous voterons contre cette notion
de rejet je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
Jordan Guitton pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente de Me écouter
chers collègues de la nups nous voterons
compte cette motion de rejet nous
voterons compte car la France va
accueillir des millions de visiteurs la
France va accueillir ces Jeux Olympiques
et c'est pour nous une vitrine
formidable je sais que vous n'aimez pas
beaucoup mettre en avant votre pays que
vous n'aimez pas beaucoup mettre en
avant notre patrimoine ou même nos
athlètes français maintenant nous nous
sommes dans une opposition sérieuse dans
une opposition sérieuse vous vous avez
proposé tout au long de l'étude de ce
texte de rejeter les caméras de rejeter
les forces de l'ordre vous proposez même
de rejeter les institutions de rejeter
le Parlement de rejeter la 5ème
République et de manière générale de
rocher ces Jeux Olympiques vous êtes
dans une opposition de destruction et je
vais vous dire chers collègues vous
faites peur aux Français vous faites
peur aux Français et c'est les mêmes les
sondages qui le disent alors nous
voterons contre cette motion de rejet
nous voterons compte car nous voulons
accueillir les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 c'est une vitrine
formidable je l'ai dit mais c'est aussi
quelque chose qui doit être réussi nous
n'avons pas énormément confiance dans ce
gouvernement nous sommes inquiets sur
les moyens mis en oeuvre par ce texte
nous vous l'avons dit nous en avons
largement débattu maintenant la question
c'est qu'est-ce que nous allons faire et
bien nous allons faire en sorte de les
accueillir en donnant le plus de force
possible et le plus de moyens possibles
à nos forces de l'ordre car oui il faut
des moyens technologiques importants
pour accueillir des millions de
visiteurs et des centaines de milliers
d'athlètes alors pourquoi voulez-vous
rejeter ce texte encore une fois vous
n'aimez pas les Jeux Olympiques vous ne
voulez rien accueillir en France vous ne
voulez rien faire vous vous êtes dans
une opposition de destruction je vous le
redis et la différence entre vous et
nous c'est que vous voulez tout vous
voulez tout détruire et nous nous
voulons tout reconstruire donc nous
votre rencontre
merci
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues s'il vous plaît bien il
y a un bruit de fond très désagréable
merci de bien vouloir vous installer
dans le silence
la parole est à Monsieur andrick Davy
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues fidèle à son tropisme
roulien avec ce projet de loi le
gouvernement fait le contraire de ce
qu'il dit vouloir faire d'abord il
présente ce projet de loi comme portant
sur les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
ce n'est pas le cas comme la signaler le
Conseil d'État plusieurs dispositions
s'appliquent à des manifestations or jop
et d'autres excèdent très largement leur
période le gouvernement prétend nous
protéger en légalisant la surveillance
par drone et le traitement algorithmique
de toutes les images or les études
commandées par la gendarmerie conclut je
cite que l'exploitation des
enregistrements de vidéoprotection
constitue une ressource de preuves et
d'indis peu rentable pour les enquêteurs
les seules vrais gagnants seront les
entreprises privées de sécurité qui
développent ces outils
sous couvert de protéger les lieux
publics là encore le gouvernement
prévoit de réduire les libertés en
rendant obligatoire les enquêtes
administratives notamment sur les
bénévoles et les salariés c'est très
grave selon le Conseil d'État près de
750 000 enquêtes seront menées
impliquant la consultation des fichiers
de police et la conservation de ces
données pendant 5 ans imaginez juste
qu'un gouvernement totalitaire hérite de
ses fichiers belle façon de nous
protéger chers collègues le gouvernement
nous dit aussi améliorer la justice le
texte prévoit que les peines seront plus
lourdes pour les délits commis lors des
manifestations sportives ou dans les
fans ce n'est pas notre conception de la
justice le gouvernement ment concernant
la dérogation au repos des dominicales
nous avons fait nos calculs elle ne
concernera pas quelques dimanches dans
l'année mais plus d'un dimanche sur deux
enfin le gouvernement qui a soi-disant
découvert le concept de sobriété prévoit
des temps des dérogations règles de
publicité pour les sponsors consommez
plus pour faire gagner plus d'argent à
total à Toyota ou Coca-Cola ce n'est pas
compatible avec la lutte contre le
changement climatique chers collègues
alors nous préférons toujours protéger à
l'aide de moyens humains plutôt que
surveiller via l'intelligence
artificielle nous préférons respecter
les libertés individuelles plutôt que
les sacrifier un impératif de sécurité
nous préférons défendre les intérêts des
travailleurs à ceux de la planète plutôt
que ceux des multinationales nous
vanterons en faveur de cette notion de
rejet
je vous remercie et avant de poursuivre
je vous informe que sur le vote de la
motion de rejet préalable je suis saisie
par le groupe renaissance d'une demande
de scrutin public qui est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée et la parole
est à Monsieur Maxime minot pour le
groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame monsieur les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues après
plusieurs plusieurs heures de débat au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale en
commission ici ou en séance nous avions
abouti un texte
doté d'outils nécessaires à la borne
d'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 lors de la
commission mixte paritaire à laquelle
j'ai assisté effectivement certains
sujets ont continué d'être au coeur des
discussions notamment le fameux article
7 qui inquiète sur de nombreux bancs ici
le sujet de l'intelligence artificielle
de ces dérives et de l'utilisation que
peut en faire l'état et notamment les
forces de l'ordre méritent bien
évidemment une discussion poussée et
c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs été fait ici
au Sénat mais également en commission
mixte paritaire
si nous regrettons la modification
adoptée ici à savoir le changement de
date de l'expérimentation de ces outils
nous ne pouvons pas autant remettre en
question l'ensemble du texte sur cette
seule déception effectivement
l'organisation de ces jeux est une
réelle opportunité pour notre pays pour
le sport amateur français et pour nos
territoires pour en faire la plus grande
réussite possible il nous faut doter le
COJO la préfecture de police de Paris et
toutes les parties prenantes de tous les
moyens nécessaires alors oui au-delà des
inquiétudes concernant les outils
technologiques nous voudrions tous
obtenir plus de garanties notamment en
matière de transport d'accessibilité
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap bref il nous faut maintenir ce
soutien pour ces Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique de Paris 2024 voter ce
projet de loi est une nécessité c'est
pourquoi le groupe les républicains
faudra contre cette motion de rejet
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe laton
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
pour pour le groupe pour le groupe modem
et indépendant évidemment nous voterons
contre cette notion de rejet le texte il
était équilibré il est équilibré depuis
que nous avons adopté un centre
d'amendement dans cette hémicycle
effectivement en commission mixte pas
intéressée par mon collègue maximinot
nous avons eu les débats sur le fait de
repousser la date qui était une volonté
du Sénat jusqu'au 31 mars 2025 c'est le
seul point de réel de divergence que
nous avons eu avec le Sénat pour le
reste l'ensemble de l'écriture ou
quasiment a été celle de l'Assemblée
nationale preuve que nous avions fait un
très bon travail dans cette hémicycle et
que nous avions adopté des mesures
protectrices il reste dans ce texte des
choses très importantes le rôle de la
CNIL très renforcé dans le cadre des
protections des libertés un centre de
garanties des libertés individuelles et
des libertés publiques de très haut
niveau qui doivent être le socle de la
discussion que nous aurons ensuite au
niveau européen sur l'iacte et c'est
pour toutes ces raisons que nous
voterons contre cette notion de rejet
je vous remercie et la parole est à
Monsieur Roger Vico pour le groupe
socialiste merci merci madame la
Présidente
nous votre rencontre cette notion de
rejet et je souhaite qu'on puisse
revenir à la définition de ce qu'est une
motion de rejet préalable la motion de
rejet préalable à deux objectifs soit
souligner qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions sont anticonstitutionnels
et pourquoi pas nous aurons un certain
nombre de remarques sur le sujet dans
les jours que viennent mais surtout
mais surtout la motion de rejet vise à
faire décider qu'il n'y a pas lieu à
délibérer or nous pensons qu'il y a lieu
à délibérer bien entendu nous allons
recevoir ici à Paris en France l'année
prochaine une manifestation unique au
monde et nous l'avons dit dès le début
de ces débats à manifestation
exceptionnelle circonstances
exceptionnelle il nous paraît légitime
de débattre de mesure exceptionnelles
par conséquent il nous semble pertinent
et même responsable de délibérer sur un
tel sur une telle manifestation une
motion de jour rejet voudrait faire
décider qu'il n'y a pas lieu à délibérer
donc nous voterons contre cette notion
de rejet en responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pris un public merci de regagner vos
places scrutin public sur la motion de
rejet préalable le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 292 exprimés
292 majorités 147 pour 60 contre 232
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté la
motion de rejet préalable
nous allons poursuivre nos travaux dans
le calme s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues que ceux qui veulent quitter
l'hémicycle le fasse sans bruit
et nous entamons donc la discussion
générale
et la parole est à madame Béatrice
Bellamy pour le groupe horizon et à
parenté
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues
l'engagement d'une nation toute entière
voilà ce qu'est l'accueil des Jeux
Olympiques
notre pays a pris un engagement devant
le CIO devant la plupart
des états de la planète devant les
athlètes du monde entier
il ne peut donc y avoir de revers ou de
Demi succès c'est l'image et le
rayonnement de la France qui est en jeu
notre propre fierté également
pour les députés horizons et apparentés
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
sont une immense opportunité pour nos
générations et les générations futures à
la fois parce que les yeux du monde
regarderont le pays de Coubertin que les
retombées économiques seront
considérables que l'héritage des JO
construit déjà la France de demain dans
cet assemblée nous avons tous conscience
du défi collectif que représente pour
notre pays l'organisation d'un événement
hors norme en matière d'aménagement du
territoire d'accueil d'inclusion mais
aussi de sécurité
c'est avec cette responsabilité
chevillée au cœur que nous nous
retrouvons pour sceller ce texte je me
réjouis comme l'ensemble de mon groupe
qu'un accord équilibré entre les
positions des deux chambres étaient
trouvées lors de la commission mixte
paritaire j'attire votre attention chers
collègues sur les compromis effectués et
les consensus trouver autour de ce texte
nos travaux ont permis de consolider le
texte initial en le rendant plus solide
et plus cohérent mais aussi plus
protecteur ce travail parlementaire
efficace menée avec des débats et des
avis divergents réhausse le Parlement
à cet égard l'écriture de l'article 7
particulièrement sujet à débattre sur
nos bancs est la preuve de ce travail
collectif en effet l'expérimentation
souhaitée par le gouvernement prendra
finalement fin au 31 mars 2025
compromis entre les dates souhaitées par
les chambres
cela permettra une parfaite connaissance
du dispositif même au-delà de la période
des jeux après le rapport rendu au
Parlement les représentants de la nation
pourront décider ou non de la
prolongation de cet outil en tout état
de cause le groupe Horizon est apparenté
salut cette avancée majeure en matière
de vidéoprotection augmentée je retiens
également du texte
issu de la CMP le retour à la rédaction
voté au sein de notre assemblée quant
aux met au Pen et amendes encourues pour
les infractions d'entrée dans les stades
salut également les peines
d'interdiction de stade prononcées en
cas de graves délit
pour le bon déroulement des épreuves
pour le respect des sportifs nous
soutenons cette mesure la lutte contre
le fléau du dopage est une priorité pour
le bon déroulé sportif et l'équité de
ces jeux c'est de l'esprit même des JO
dont il s'agit c'est pourquoi la
proposition des sénateurs de pérenniser
dans le code du sport les comparaisons
d'empreintes génétiques ou les examens
de caractéristiques génétiques a été
retenue
cette mesure n'est autre qu'une mise en
conformité de notre droit national avec
le code mondial antidopage je la salue
le groupe Horizon est apparenté et
convaincu que ce projet de loi donne les
moyens à la France de réussir ses jeux
aux collectivités de suivre la dynamique
à la fête populaire de prendre son envol
aux athlètes de réaliser sereinement
leur performances et à tous l'écosystème
de profiter de ce moment d'exception
nous approuvons les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire et nous
voterons ce texte tout en restant
particulièrement attentif à l'héritage
des Jeux Olympiques et la mobilisation
des territoires pour cela nous comptons
sur vous madame la madame la ministre et
nous vous en remercions à 472 jours de
cette grande fête universelle la France
franchit les haies les unes après les
autres il en reste encore eu encore de
nombreuses avec ce texte en voici une de
moins je suis impatiente d'être dans le
sprint final je vous remercie
merci Madame Bellamy
la parole est à Madame Sandra rogol pour
le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
désolé j'avais pas le coeur
les JO et encore plus les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques sont une
fête une fête qui intègre des valeurs de
respect de partage de paix et de
dialogues on en est pas tout à fait là
dans ce texte nous avons eu plusieurs
fois l'occasion de parler de ce texte
c'est-à-dire que nous en avons des battu
je vous le disais tout à l'heure serait
un tantinet excessif mais au moins on a
pu parler
les sénateurs avaient fait le choix de
mesures particulièrement dur contre les
libertés en première lecture avec peu
d'impact je le rappelle sur la sécurité
des populations aggrava encore des
mesures qui étaient dans le texte
initial et qui était dénoncé à l'origine
par les associations de protection des
droits et libertés
la liberté oui c'est une valeur
fondamentale de notre démocratie et de
notre République pourtant ça défend
c'est un combat de chaque instant rien
jamais n'est acquis concernant les
libertés qu'elles soient individuelles
ou collectives et ce texte vient de nous
rappeler combien de combattre pour ses
droits et complexes et difficiles quand
on ne mesure la disparition des libertés
coscillante qu'elles imposent quand on
les a trop abîmés pour qu'elle puisse
encore nous protéger mais soutenu par la
droite et l'extrême droite vous proposez
de doter le pays de moyens qui
permettrait de traquer traquer oui par
une vidéo surveillance à analyse
biométrique les personnes et alors où ce
gouvernement désigne ses ennemis ce ne
sont plus les ennemis de la République
mais les ennemis qu'il désigne ce sont
les défenseurs des droits cette
perspective a de quoi inquiéter aucun
pays européen aucun pays démocratique
n'est allé aussi loin que ce que propose
ce texte
alors on aurait pu rêver d'une France je
sais pas leader de la transition ou de
la bifurcation écologique une France qui
œuvre des perspectives de développement
social écologique économique à sa
jeunesse et à son pays
mais on a ce projet de loi qui n'a donc
d'olympisme que le nom et qui lui mise
sur tout autre chose le choix d'un pays
qui soit leader dans le recul des
libertés et le développement de la
surveillance automatisée de sa
population c'est une belle perspective
pour la jeunesse qui donne les lycées
les écoles les universités demandent le
droit à un avenir et propose elle-même
les moyens de construire une société du
vivre mieux vous leur répondez donc en
tout cynisme avec l'article 12
spécialement calibré contre les
modalités d'action qu'il développe afin
d'alerter sur l'urgence environnementale
et je pense qu'ils elles ont bien reçu
le message nous aussi d'ailleurs plus
vite dans la répression plus haut dans
le déni et plus fort dans la
surveillance généralisée de la
population
l'Assemblée avait pourtant malgré tout
un réussi à limiter à la marge certains
des reculent de ce texte passez à notre
goût évidemment mais dans sa sagesse
cette hémicycle avait limité les
dispositifs de surveillance de l'article
7 dans le temps il commençait bien avant
le début des JO et continu bien après
leur forme mais au moins ces
expérimentations prenaient fin avec
l'année 2024 la CMP a choisi de pousser
jusqu'au printemps 2025 ceux qui
ressemble de moins en moins une
expérimentation et de plus en plus à une
installation par étape de dispositifs
dangereux pour nos libertés qu'elle
recule pour le pays qui inscrit liberté
aux frontis fils de tous ces bâtiments
le territoire français pourra donc sans
lien aucun avec les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques être couvert de caméra
dotées d'algorithmes en mesure
d'identifier ce qu'on a appelé des
comportements anormaux nous en avons
longuement disserté ici sans obtenir la
moindre qualification juridique quel
agent quel juge pourra quantifier la
dose de normalité acceptable ou non nous
l'ignorons de nombreux organisations ont
alerté sur les dangers de cet article 7
en particulier les dangers pour les
droits et libertés des Françaises et des
Français qu'il s'agisse du Conseil
national des barreaux ou de la Ligue des
droits de l'homme et je voudrais rendre
hommage à cette Ligue des droits de
l'homme pour son travail sans relâche
pour nos droits et libertés contre les
forces obscurantistes du 19e siècle sur
jusqu'à nos jours
et ce malgré les attaques les remises en
question et les campagnes visant à la
discrédité on en avait encore une ces
derniers jours cerise sur le gâteau elle
est personnelle celle-là encore la CMP a
choisi de supprimer les maigres
victoires que nous avions eu sur les
violences sexuelles et sexistes en
retirant l'article 1 bis qui mettait en
place des campagnes de prévention comme
sur les précédentes CMP les sénateurs
ont choisi encore une fois de supprimer
tout ce qui permet de lutter contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes on ne
rencontrant aucune opposition de la part
des députés de la CMP tout en symbole
aujourd'hui ce texte aurait pu tenir les
promesses olympiques sur le sport
l'écologie l'accessibilité le fameux
héritage mais le seul héritage ce seront
les maladies chroniques des enfants du
groupe scolaire Anatole Pleyel explosé
aux particules fines ou l'école Louis
Lumière qui perd son école tout ceci est
tellement éloigné de l'esprit de
l'olympisme que nous voterons évidemment
contre je vous remercie madame rogol
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane peu
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur cher collègue la
loi olympique à chef son parcours
aujourd'hui
celui-ci aurait pu se dérouler sans
accroc si le texte était concentré sur
les mesures permettant d'organiser cet
événement aussi important pour notre
pays cette loi aurait dû être à l'image
de ce que nous attendons des jeux c'est
à dire un moment de concorde d'union
nationale autour d'un objectif commun
seulement le gouvernement a fait le
choix d'y introduire un nombre important
de disposition sans lien direct avec les
Jeux Olympiques l'article 7 sur le
traitement algorithmique de la
vidéoprotection est un point de
désaccord important et nous regrettons
l'obstination du gouvernement est
utilisé les jeux comme une
expérimentation à viser pérenne de même
les nouvelles dérogations au travail
dominical ne nous apparaissent pas
justifiés et nous déplorons qu'elles
aient été conçues sans y associer les
membres de la Charte sociale ni les
syndicats et même si nous avons
apprécié les avancées lors du débat nous
avons aussi noté que pendant la CMT les
avancées obtenues ici ont été réduites à
peau de chagrin dans le cadre de la
commission mixte paritaire
enfin les dispositifs renforçant la
répression dans les stades nous
apparaissent une mauvaise réponse à la
lutte partagée contre la violence dans
les stades nous soutenons cependant
toute une série de mesures relatives à
la borne organisation des jeux à la
lutte antidopage en particulier
l'article 5 rédigé de manière
respectueuse des compétences de chacun
grâce au travail entre autres du
président botterson de saint-dener à
Tahiti en passant par Marseille
Châteauroux les jeux ne seront réussis
que s'ils sont populaires les événements
sportifs comme la Semaine Olympique
doivent se multiplier du contenu doit
être mis derrière les labels comme terre
de jeux ou génération 2024 avec mon
collègue Stéphane Mazard nous menons une
mission d'information sur les retombées
des jeux ce que nous dit le mouvement
sportif
le sport scolaire et universitaire c'est
qu'ils ont beaucoup d'espoir dans les
jeux pour enclencher des politiques
publiques et des moyens en faveur de la
pratique sportive mais que pour
l'instant c'est encore beaucoup trop
timide vous l'avez vous-même dit madame
la ministre le sport à l'école et la
mère des batailles mais il faut en
convaincre le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et mettre fin aux centaines de
suppressions de poste de professeurs
d'éducation physique et sportive depuis
le dernier mandat surtout il faut
consacrer le PS comme une véritable
matière scolaire et nos propositions
sont sur la table depuis la proposition
de loi soit la démocratie
démocratisation du sport que nous avions
déposé lors du précédent quinquennat
nous souhaitons 4 heures de PS au
collège pour toutes et tous sa présence
comme épreuve à part entière dans le
diplôme national du brevet nous
souhaitons voir se développer Lucette
qui existe dans 20% des établissements
pour l'instant mais qui licencie 700 000
enfants à l'instar de l'UNSS le sport
scolaire et la passer entre l'école et
les clubs c'est un outil autrement plus
puissant que les 30 minutes d'activités
quotidiennes nous souhaitons également
la nomination d'un référent EPS dans
chaque école élémentaire parmi les
professeurs épaulés par des conseillers
pédagogiques mais il y a tellement à
faire profitons des jeux pour impulser
une grande loi cadre sur le sport
donnant une trajectoire budgétaire
ascendante pour le sport lui qui ne
représente que 0,3% du budget de l'État
et qui est pourtant si présent dans la
vie de nos concitoyens alors au
lendemain de cette loi mettons-nous
enfin au travail pour construire ce
service public du sport en faveur d'une
culture sportive pour toutes et tous que
nous souhaitons construire madame la
ministre la Seine-Saint-Denis accueille
le centre aquatique olympique c'est une
excellente nouvelle nous accueillerons
également des nouveaux bassins
mais si dans deux trois ou quatre ans il
y a toujours plus d'un enfant sur deux
dans ce département qui ne s'est pas
nager alors toutes les médailles
rapportées par nos athlètes ne pourront
masquer l'échec des ambitions affichées
enfin l'un des gros enjeux sera le
transport les difficultés sont
importantes et tout le monde s'accorde à
dire que l'ouverture à la concurrence
débute en région parisienne au 31
décembre 2024 dans ce contexte n'est
absolument pas raisonnable il faut il
surseoir comme je l'ai fait dans une
proposition de loi qui commencera sa
discussion ce soir en commission nous
pensons
notre groupe est extrêmement favorable
aux Jeux Olympiques nous pensons que
c'est une chance et une responsabilité
pour la France nous nous voulons nous
voulons nous donner tous les moyens pour
les réussir et pour y parvenir nous
aurions souhaité voté ce texte il y a
des articles qui nous en empêchent alors
nous nous abstiendrons
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
bien madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues je pense que nous avons tous
hâte de dire que les jeux commencent et
désormais nous devons tous être
mobilisés ensemble pour permettre le bon
déroulement de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui se tiendront à Paris
dans d'autres villes et dans d'autres
territoires du 24 juillet au 8 septembre
2024 il nous reste pour cela à valider
cet accord trouvé en CMP sur cette
version finale du projet de loi
notre groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires soutient ce
texte adopté dans la continuité du
travail mené à l'assemblée qui a permis
de trouver un meilleur équilibre entre
en jeu sécurité et liberté publique et
nous saluons en particulier les avancées
sur le plan de l'offre de soins de
l'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap ainsi que sur la lutte
contre le dopage
alors tout d'abord nous comprenons les
mesures liées à la sécurité pendant les
jeux mais nous appelons à leur
utilisation équilibrée et dont le cadre
strict et des garanties fixés par la loi
et nous estimons qu'il est important de
maintenir un équilibre avec la liberté
fondamentale
la puissance des outils de surveillance
appellent des garde-fous et laisse
parfois craindre une périnisation du
dispositif
en première lecture plusieurs
amendements de notre groupe ont été
ardomptés adoptés afin de mieux encadrer
le recours inédit à l'intelligence
artificielle en matière de vidéo
surveillance
la CMP a permis d'encadrer encore plus
cette expérimentation et nous saluons
notamment le choix d'inscrire dans la
loi l'obligation d'éviter lors de la
phase d'apprentissage le développement
de toute mauvaise utilisation
s'agissons de l'utilisation des scanners
corporels pour l'accès aux enceintes
sportives notre groupe n'a pas
d'objection de principes et a fait
adopter un amendement pour améliorer
l'information publique celle-ci doit
être préalable et rappelé au spectateur
la possibilité de refuser de se
soumettre au scanner
notre groupe salut également les efforts
introduits par le Sénat pour renforcer
le volet prévention
il est aussi important de noter de
prévenir et sanctionner davantage les
violences lors des manifestations
sportives de fait les peines
individuelles applicables sont durcis
les infractions liées à l'intrusion dans
une ancêtre sportive ou sur un terrain
de sport sans renforcer nous avons
cependant un regret par rapport au texte
sorti de la CMP il concerne l'article
premier bis que notre assemblée avait
adopté et qui visait à prévoir une
campagne de prévention des violences
sexistes et sexuelles sur les sites des
Jeux Olympiques ce dernier a été
supprimé notre groupe rappelle que par
le passé et un passé pas si lointain
plusieurs sportifs et associations ont
dénoncé les pratiques et comportements
sexistes dans le milieu sportif cette
campagne n'était absolument pas
superflue et aller indéniablement dans
le bon sens
enfin si nous savons que malheureusement
ces jeux ne seront pas à 100%
accessibles aux personnes en situation
de handicap comme le voulait notamment
un certain nombre d'associations parmi
celles-ci le collectif handicap notre
groupe tient tout de même à souligner
l'importance de l'effort pour améliorer
l'accessibilité des transports publics
pendant les épreuves alors bien sûr on
ne peut pas faire fille de certains
lampes d'inquiétudes qui subsistent sur
les chantiers des transports notamment
madame la ministre des retards sur la
ligne du Grand Paris Express
Île-de-France mobilité contre un de
renforce de renoncer un appel d'offres
pour le transport des athlètes et des
officiers après un premier appel d'offre
infructueux sur les dépenses de sécurité
nous sommes encore aujourd'hui à se
demander si nous allons pouvoir recruter
les 20-25 000 agents contenus des
difficultés sur le domaine du travail
d'ailleurs un rapport de la Cour des
comptes de janvier 2023 pointe un risque
de dérapage financier
enfin bien sûr les dérapages budgétaires
qui sont le pendant de ce genre de
manifestations mais aujourd'hui madame
je vous sais pleinement engagé pour la
réussite de cet événement ce texte
apporte quoi qu'il en soit un soutien
indispensable pour l'organisation de ce
rendez-vous planétaire cet événement
doit maintenant nous fédérer nous devons
tous être unis pour qu'il soit une
réussite pour nous pour notre population
pour les visiteurs et pour la France
aussi notre groupe votre majoritairement
pour ce texte
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur belle qui Rebel
la date pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
madame messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues je veux d'abord
commencer mes propos par des
remerciements d'abord à votre endroit
madame la ministre des Sports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques ainsi que
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outre-mer pour votre écoute la
qualité et la précision de vos réponses
à nos questions tout au long de la
procédure législative qui ont grandement
facilité l'avancement et la qualité de
nos travaux des remerciements également
à nos rapporteurs Guillaume Vittet
Bertrand sort Béatrice Bellamy Stéphane
Mazard et Christine Lena bord c'est avec
Honor et fierté que nous recevrons le
monde et c'est Jeux Olympiques seront
plus qu'un rendez-vous sportif c'est un
moment de cohésion nationale de
fraternité humaine de grandes fêtes
populaires partout en France et
d'ailleurs les territoires d'outre-mer
le puissant pouvoir unificateur des jeux
se traduit aussi par la solidarité entre
les sociétés et plus de solidarité au
sein des sociétés la solidarité signifie
beaucoup plus que le simple respect ou
la non discrimination la solidarité
c'est céder partager prendre soin des
autres qu'on nous disons être ouvert au
monde c'est par exemple accueillir des
athlètes réfugiés et nous démontrerons à
quel point les réfugiés sont un
enrichissement pour la société comment
alors peut-on être contre les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques organiser un
tel événement sur le plan logistique
sécurité billetterie transport avec
quatre cérémonies d'ouverture et de
clôture et d'un défi monumental que nous
relèverons collectivement nous allons
innover avec la cérémonie d'ouverture
qui mettra la scène en scène aux yeux du
monde entier nous devront être au
rendez-vous de ces jeux tout comme celui
de la durabilité ce projet de loi nous
rassemble est au final un texte de
compromis auquel chaque groupe aura
contribué et je salue au nom du groupe
Renaissance l'accord trouvé en CMP qui
vous permet de franchir une étape
importante avec de nombreux
améliorations j'en citerai quelques-unes
concernant la lutte contre le dopage la
rédaction finale permettra d'assurer
l'information express du sportif au
moment de son inscription à la
compétition
s'agissant des deux nouveaux délits
réprimant l'entrée
frauduleuses dans une enceinte sportive
je veux saluer le travail de président
de la commission des lois chère Sacha et
les modifications apportées au régime
des interdictions administratives de
stade la CMP a par ailleurs renforcé les
garanties apportées en matière de
protection de données dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation du traitement
algorithmique de la vidéourveillance
prévue à l'article 7 je salue sur ce
point le compromis équilibré trouver
avec nos collègues sénateurs quand on
termine de l'expérimentation fixée au 31
mars 2025 je me réjouis enfin du
maintien de la rédaction à l'Assemblée
nationale celle de l'Assemblée nationale
s'agissant du ciblage de
l'expérimentation sur les taxis
accessibles aux personnes utilisatrices
de fauteuil roulant faire en sorte que
les jeux soient pleinement inclusifs est
une priorité les mesures de ce projet de
loi sont justifiés et proportionnés
compte tenu de l'ampleur de l'événement
elles permettent de concilier à la fois
la nécessité absolue de sécurité et le
respect des libertés individuelles la
sécurité n'est pas une option elle est
une nécessité face aux menaces
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés je
regrette les positions des certaines de
nos oppositions qui prennent en otage le
débat sur ce projet de loi
c'est un manque de responsabilité à
moins de 500 jours du début de la
compétition car ces jeux sont d'abord
une chance et une formidable opportunité
de créer des vocations de susciter le
développement des pratiques sportives
partout et pour tous en France et dans
les outre-mer d'en faire un vecteur
d'émancipation et d'inclusion de rénover
de créer des équipements en somme faire
de notre pays une nation sportive notre
regard porte au-delà de l'horizon des
jeux c'est celui de l'héritage réussir
est un impératif et accueillir les Jeux
olympiques paralympiques nous oblige à
tout point de vue comme le voulait
Pierre de Coubertin nous avons vu loin
nous avons parlé franc et nous avons agi
ferme
je vous appelle toutes et tous à voter
pour un texte qui ne peut que nous
réunir pour faire ensemble de ces jeux
un succès un motif de fierté et d'unité
de notre pays je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jordan Guitton
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègue à chaque mois
son scandale à chaque mois une affaire
chaque mois notre pays est ridiculisé et
à chaque fois vous faites fille de ne
rien voir et de ne rien entendre alors
que nous discutons des Jeux Olympiques
2024 nous venons d'apprendre la semaine
dernière que la France a été écartée et
punie selon le journal L'Équipe de
l'organisation de l'Euro féminin 2025 à
cause du fiasco de la dernière finale de
la Ligue des Champions Stade de France
et de la situation sécuritaire du pays
une question sommes-nous prêts
aujourd'hui et l'année prochaine à
accueillir les Jeux olympiques de 2024
ce texte est son évolution illustre
l'incohérence du gouvernement et de sa
majorité nous alertions depuis le début
de l'examen de ce projet de loi sur
votre méthode qui vise à tromper le plus
possible la représentation nationale
voilà vous gouvernement qui continuait à
utiliser ces Jeux Olympiques comme
prétexte afin de mettre en œuvre des
petites mesures sécuritaires que nous
animé même pas la tergiversation des
dates sur l'expérimentation des caméras
algorithmiques et la meilleure
illustration votre en même temps en fait
vous n'assumez pas d'installer ces
caméras dans le temps et dans l'espace
vous utilisez des dates
d'expérimentation pour en faire une
généralisation durant 9 mois alors que
les Jeux Olympiques durent deux mois
votre majorité semble perdue ici comme
dans la gestion du travail parlementaire
car même sur un texte qui aurait voulu
être consensuel sur les Jeux Olympiques
vous arrivez à diviser l'assemblée car
vous utilisez ce texte à des fins
politiques alors nous vous faisons ici
une réponse politique je note que même
l'amendement transpartisan qui visait à
stocker les données de nos concitoyens
en Europe a été modifié vous devenez
sectaire même sur un amendement de bon
sens
tout d'abord nous sommes inquiets sur la
multiplication des expérimentations pour
ces Jeux Olympiques que ce soit pour les
caméras mais aussi pour les formations
accélérées de la sécurité privée et en
réalité il vous a fallu presque 5 ans
pour donner quelques moyens aux forces
de l'ordre lors de la loopi et
maintenant vous attendez les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 pour doter la France
d'équipements à la hauteur de l'enjeu
mais ces technologies ne seront
efficaces que si votre volonté politique
s'affirme réellement et que vos réponses
soient fermes vis-à-vis des délinquants
la seule fermeté que vous avez elle est
dans vos propos mais les Français
attendent eux des actes et c'est bien le
problème vous êtes des communicants
absolument pas des acteurs de la
sécurité c'est pour cela que l'UEFA
dénonce votre impréparation dans
l'affaire du Stade de France est-ce
sérieux d’exprime rimenter alors que la
France va accueillir des millions de
visiteurs l'année prochaine sur
l'affaire du Stade de France vous
réagissez par des mots paniqués par le
scandale mondial que cela génère mais à
côté vous refusez sur ce sexe
d'augmenter les peines et mettre en
place des amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles dissuasives pour
sanctionner rapidement et fermement ce
qui pénétreront sans billets dans les
stades même après cette affaire vous
refusez nous écouter et de mettre fin à
votre laxisme votre gouvernement est
totalement déconnecté de la réalité vous
ne traitez jamais des causes et
malheureusement malheureusement la
réalité nous donne raison même dans son
dernier ouvrage Didier l'allemand ancien
préfet police de Paris nous donne raison
et je vais vous lire un passage et il
nous donne raison rassemblement national
qui dénonce depuis des années
l'immigration la population délinquante
est nourrie par une immigration
chaotique je cite encore Didier
l'allemand à Paris un délit sur deux est
commis par un étranger dont beaucoup
sont en situation irrégulière ils sont à
l'origine de 90 à 95% des vols à la tire
nous avions donc raison depuis le début
sur l'immigration et vous le saviez très
bien
alors qu'attendez-vous qu'attendez-vous
pour appliquer les obligations de
quitter le territoire français ou pour
appliquer tout simplement la loi
peut-être prenez enfin la mesure de
l'ampleur de votre négligence politique
alors que la délinquance en France avec
une agression gratuite toutes les 44
secondes et devenu le quotidien des
Français alors sans enthousiasme sans
grande confiance en vous mais dans de le
seul but de donner les quelques moyens
utiles dans l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques nous voterons ce texte suite
à l'examen en commission mixte paritaire
ce vote nous le faisons pour les forces
de l'ordre ce vote nous le faisons pour
que ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
se déroulent dans les meilleures
conditions possibles ce n'est pas un
vote de confiance et la confiance
d'ailleurs vous l'avez jamais vraiment
eu en juin 2022 le peuple français vous
a placé en situation de minorité
présidentielle dans cette assemblée en
mars 2023 il y a quelques semaines cette
assemblée vous a placé à 9 voix de la
censure voter en même temps vous divise
de l'intérieur et vous amène à passer en
force et même parfois à voter contre des
propositions de loi sur la récidive de
vos propres alliés vous n'avez plus de
légitimité politique vous avez perdu le
combat des idées depuis bien longtemps
et vous avez perdu le peuple français
qui nous vous fait plus confiance toutes
ces impréparations et toutes ces
incohérences devraient vous faire
changer mais vous ignorez la réalité et
puisque vous refusez de changer contre
la vie du peuple français alors il vous
remplacera car pour changer la politique
il faut changer les politiques et ça les
Français l'ont bien compris
je vous remercie et avant de poursuivre
je vous informe que sur le vote du texte
de la CMP je suis saisie par le groupe
renaissance d'une demande de scrutin
public il est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale la parole est à
monsieur Éric Coquerel pour le groupe la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue avant de donner
les raisons de mon opposition et celle
de mon groupe à cette nouvelle loi
olympique je voulais dire d'où je parle
comme on dit tout d'abord depuis ma
circonscription d'élection la première
de Seine-Saint-Denis qui va concentrer
une bonne part des activités olympiques
village olympique entre Saint-Denis
Saint-Denis et Saint-Ouen Stade de
France où le centre aquatique olympique
ensuite surtout j'allais dire depuis mon
activité professionnelle passée qui m'a
amené à travailler sur les Jeux
d'Athènes Pékin et Londres pour bien les
connaître c'est la raison qui me pousse
aujourd'hui à dire que je ne rejette pas
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques par
principe je témoigne que les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques constituent
indéniablement une grande fête sportive
et populaire souvent fraternelle sur les
sites sportifs et dans les tribunes le
Casio aussi une fois tous les quatre ans
de mettre en avant des disciplines et
sportifs qui vivent le reste du temps
dans la différence médiatique avec les
conséquences imaginables sur leur
pratique plus de masse mais j'observe
que les Jeux Olympiques paralympiques
ont aussi constitué postérieurement un
bilan négatif pour plusieurs des pays
qui les ont accueillis ce fut notamment
le cas pour Athènes le Brésil évidemment
Tokyo en pleine crise du covid la
démesure prise par ces événements la
rigueur du cahier des charges du CIO
sous contrainte de sponsor qui sont au
timbres autant de multinationales le
gonflement des budgets nécessaires ont
laissé bien des plaies pour les
habitants des villes d'accueil récemment
des athlètes reconnus se sont aussi
interrogés sur le coup carbone de telles
épreuves à l'heure de l'urgence
environnementale je pense à Nicolas
Karabatic à plan a changé de modèle le
18 septembre 2022 sur France Inter et de
passer toutes les organisations
d'épreuves sportives au crible
d'affaires play écologique ces
inquiétudes je les partage également
pour les jeux de paris 2024 je les
évoque n'ont pas pour remettre
aujourd'hui en question leur existence
ils auront lieu mais pour que l'on
puisse encore influer sur leur
organisation lors des roulements et leur
héritage or sont nombreux et cette
nouvelle loi c'est bien le problème les
agravent d'abord la dimension
sécuritaire c'est l'une des
caractéristiques des JO modernes
d'imposer un dispositif policier
toujours plus importantes pour des sites
sportifs et les différents villages au
point que les populations résidentes se
voient privées d'un accès à des zones de
vie qui font pourtant partie de leur
quotidien ce qui s'est passé lors de la
finale de la Coupe d'Europe de foot des
clubs en mai dernier au tour du stade de
France bien que le rapport a surtout des
responsabilités à l'organisation ce
jour-là n'a fait que renforcer ce climat
sécuritaire au point de proposer des
innovations expérimentations
inquiétantes en matière de liberté
publique la légalisation de l'assurance
de masse grâce à l'association de la
vidéo surveillance et de traitement
algorithmique est une nouvelle étape
inquiétante de la surveillance
généralisée des populations
mesures d'exception encore avec une
longue liste de délits qui feront
l'objet d'aggravation de peine dans
toutes les enceintes sportives c'est
enfin la surveillance et l’offichage de
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
est enterrées dans cette des données qui
sur décision administratives pour être
conservées pendant 5 ans et qui sont
maintenus monsieur le rapporteur
contrairement à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure CIO nous ont été présentés
comme inclusive vis-à-vis des
populations des territoires qui les
accueillent avec ces dispositifs et
aussi une certaine idéologie ségrégative
qui cible les jeunes de nos villes
populaires comme des ennemis de
l'intérieur je me réfère par exemple à
ce titre d'un quotidien droite bien
connu expliquant je cite à 500 jours de
la cérémonie dévoiler le plan de
bataille de l'exécutif pour pacifier la
Seine-Saint-Denis je crains que les
premières victimes de ces dispositifs
sécuritaires soit les populations
notamment jeunes de notre département il
est aussi encore temps de revoir à la
baisse certaines configurations de
cérémonie notamment celle d'ouverture si
cela doit appeler à des dispositifs
sécuritaires hors proportion avec les
jeux humains qu'on nous a promis
ensuite dérogation encore avec la
marchandisation à outrance de l'espace
public avec notamment des dérogations
avec de publicité d'affichage grand
format au profit des partenaires des JO
enfin avec le recul des droits des
travailleurs notamment avec ce que la
loi prévente prévoit en termes de
dérogation au repos dominicales ce
dernier aspect renvoie un autre crainte
que je sais partager par le tissu
économique de mon département que les
répercussions économiques ne profitent
guère aux habitants des territoires
concernés car j'observe que si les
dérogats ont facilement été voté en
faveur de la publicité ou du tout
sécuritaire cela n'a pas été le cas pour
favoriser par exemple des entreprises et
des travailleurs de Seine-Saint-Denis
les règles libérales du CIO des marchés
publics ont favorisé souvent le moins 10
ans financier pour décrocher des
contrats
de manière générale je crains
aujourd'hui que les jeunes de
Seine-Saint-Denis se partagent plutôt
les postes de volontaires de bénévoles
de stagiaires que des emplois
directement induits par les jeux
même si ce n'est pas le thème de la loi
je tiens aussi à dire mon inquiétude sur
l'héritage urbanistique des JO si et je
tiens à un rendommage à la solideo le
fait d'avoir réussi à aménager un espace
de cette façon là qui sera prête en même
temps bâtiment école service public et
des dispositifs notamment écologiques
doit tout à la planification écologique
je dis mon inquiétude sur
laurenthérissement du prix des logements
que va induire les JO pas seulement et
qui pourraient pousser aujourd'hui des
actuels habitants à aller toujours plus
loin en conclusion j'appelle à toujours
plus de vigilance citoyenne pour les
libertés publiques les retombées
économiques et pour l'héritage sportif
et la parole est à Monsieur Maxime minot
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
nous voici enfin dans la dernière ligne
droite à moi nous 500 jours des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 le Parlement d'un accord commun
entre les deux chambres va permettre de
doter l'État et les organisateurs de
tous les moyens nécessaires pour faire
de ces jeux la plus grande des réussites
nous avons pris le temps d'étudier
chaque composante de ce texte et d'en
faire un outil abouti pour répondre aux
enjeux qu'imposent une telle
organisation
lors de la commission mixte paritaire
très peu de changements ont été
effectués comparé au texte que nous
avions voté ici il y a deux semaines
nous pouvons cependant regretter
certaines modifications à commencer par
l'abandon de l'inscription dans ce texte
de la mise en place d'une campagne de
lutte contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes au sein des villages des
athlètes et des médias si les signatures
ont souligné qu'un travail était déjà
engagé entre le Kojo et les associations
il ne semblait pas de trop de l'inscrire
de manière explicite dans le texte ce
sujet malheureusement encore bien trop
souvent présent dans l'actualité
notamment dans le monde du sport doit
être au cœur de toutes les vigilances
durant l'événement
de plus l'article 7 qui a été au cœur
des discussions intenses notamment ici
au sein de cette hémicycle a connu
quelques changements qui laissent planer
quelques doutes le changement du 31
décembre 2024 au 31 mars 2025 concernant
la période d'utilisation des outils liés
à l'intelligence artificielle ne semble
pas utile à l'heure où les inquiétudes
sont réelles face à l'émergence des
outils technologiques si au sein des
républicains nous soutenons bien
évidemment cette expansion des
dispositifs nous devons faire preuve de
vigilance à ce sujet et nous mettons en
garde le gouvernement face aux éventuels
dérives durant ces semaines de
compétition nos forces de l'ordre
doivent être préparées en nombre
suffisants et armés des bons outils pour
lutter à la fois contre la délinquance
protéger les sites de compétition et
intervenir en cas de nécessité
nous pouvons pas nous retrouver dépassé
par la situation à l'heure où le monde
aura les yeux rivés sur nous c'est de la
responsabilité de l'État et du Kojo de
maintenir une protection de tout instant
de tous les spectateurs habitant et
touristes
face à cette impératif les forces de
l'ordre et l'armée vont grandement être
sollicités par ce grand événement la
solution était pourtant toute trouvée
faire appel aux réservistes en vain
l'amendement que je portais à ce sur ce
sujet et que le gouvernement avait
également déposé a été déclaré
irrecevable
j'ai donc décidé avec plusieurs de mes
collègues les républicains mais aussi
avec les membres du groupe de travail en
charge du suivi de ces jeux et d'autres
venus de tous les bancs de porter cette
solution au sein d'une proposition de
loi que j'ai déposé la semaine dernière
cette proposition nous espérons tous
qu'elle sera prochainement étudiée dans
cette hémicycle je dis nous l'espérons
car depuis plusieurs jours le bruit
court que le groupe Renaissance aurait
changé de position à ce sujet et les
députés Renaissance ont eu ordre de
retirer leur cosse signature de mon
texte
je ne peux cacher mon étonnement dès
lors que ce dispositif avait pourtant
été écrit conjointement avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur et avec le soutien de la
ministre des Sports
quelle déception serait si cette
position de loi venait à ne pas être
programmée à l'ordre du jour avec pour
seul raisons l'envie éventuelle de punir
certains d'entre nous d'avoir voté la
motion de censure contre la réforme des
retraites
je n'ose imaginer que le jeu politique
prenne le dessus sur un sujet aussi
trans partisan et aussi important
qu'elle organisation de ces jeux j'ai
été présent de la première seconde à la
dernière sur ce texte vous le savez nous
avons tous nos convictions mais en tant
qu'a élu de la Nation nous avons pour
seul responsabilité de répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens je vous ai
souvent combattu
mais ce texte je le défendu ici à la
semaine nationale comme ailleurs or les
murs je l'ai pleinement soutenu et
malgré votre sectarisme je continuerai à
être un appui fidèle dans l'organisation
de cette belle fête populaire
j'espère donc sincèrement pouvoir
compter sur la sagesse de tous pour que
cet outil que nous défendons avec
plusieurs de mes collègues puissent voir
le jour et servir l'intérêt commun de
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
j'ai bien conscience que ma proposition
n'est pas révolutionnaire mais elle est
un pas de plus pour une meilleure
sécurité pour les jeux notre pays en a
besoin aujourd'hui plus que jamais que
nous soyons mobilisés ensemble au-delà
de toutes divergence politique faisons
du rêve de ces jeux une réalité ouvrons
grand les jeux c'est pourquoi le groupe
les républicains votera pour ce texte
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe laton
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs et rapporteurs pour avis mes
chers collègues
nous voici arrivés au terme du parcours
législatif au Parlement du projet de loi
sur les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
à l'occasion de la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est déroulée au Sénat le
texte n'a connu qu'une modification
notable concernant le terme de
l'expérimentation de vidéoprotection
laquelle sera dorénavant bornée au 31
mars 2025 à l'Assemblée nous souhaitions
le 31 décembre 2024 le Sénat le 30 juin
2025 il s'agit donc d'un compromis qui
correspond d'ailleurs à un amendement de
repli que nous avions déposé lors de
l'examen à l'Assemblée
je ne le marteau regardez jamais assez
ce texte garanti grâce à l'ensemble des
institutions politiques et à nos
autorités administratives indépendantes
le respect des libertés individuelles
nous n'avons en effet passé à la
tentation du solutionnisme technologique
contrairement à ce que prétendent des
détracteurs qui confondent souvent avec
une bonne dose de mauvaise foi
videoprotection algorée algorithmique et
biométrie pas de modèle à la chinoise
donc nous ne serons ni dans le monde
dorwell ni en démocratures les Français
peuvent être rassurés pour ma part je
serai je m'y engage particulièrement
vigilant sur la mise en eau sur le
terrain le moment venu et notamment sur
les matériels et les logiciels utilisés
afin que le curseur reste bloqué à une
position d'équilibre entre la protection
et la sécurité des participants et la
préservation des libertés
cet équilibre n’était pas facile à
trouver mais j'ai la conviction nous
sommes que nous y sommes arrivés ce qui
dans le contexte plus général souvent ou
le des débats actuels représente une
victoire à laquelle le groupe démocrate
toujours soucieux de la recherche d'un
compromis à pleinement participé
mais on a eu tendance à l'oublier ce
texte ne se limite pas à son article 7
si aprement discuter et à ses enjeux de
sécurité il a balayé l'ensemble des
problématiques posées par l'organisation
d'un événement d'une telle ampleur et
notamment la lutte contre le dopage
grâce à la mise en conformité du
dispositif avec les recommandations du
Comité international olympique où la
sécurisation de la délivrance des
billets afin de limiter les escroqueries
ces jeux doivent être aussi doivent être
aussi éthiques ne l'oublions pas ils
doivent contribuer au rayonnement
international de notre pays à redorer
aussi une image passablement ternie par
les événements du Stade de France où le
spectacle offert par Paris et certaines
grandes villes défigurées par les
poubelles et dégradations des casseurs
nous sommes plus que jamais contraint à
l'excellence et ce texte de loi devrait
je le pense sincèrement nous aider à y
parvenir
cet épisode législatif a
particulièrement particulièrement mis en
exergue le rôle essentiel de la CNIL est
souligné s'il en était besoin le rôle
déterminant est grandissant de cette
commission pour la protection de nos
libertés individuelles et collectives
par ailleurs le groupe démocrate
remercie de nouveau le mystère de
l'Intérieur et celui des sports pour la
qualité des échanges et du travail
fourni auprès du Parlement et ce à
chacune des étapes du processus
législatif
pour autant la qualité de nos échanges
aurait mérité d'être constamment nourri
grâce à notre interlocuteur naturel et
privilégié qui est le mystère chargé des
relations avec le Parlement qui fut et
encore aujourd'hui est absent dommage
une co-construction active et pourtant
le gage d'un intérêt général assuré nous
voterons donc le texte de la CMP je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Roger Vico pour
le groupe socialiste et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur
taxe exceptionnel nous l'avons dit à
l'occasion à la faveur d'une
manifestation tout à fait exceptionnelle
qui méritait ce texte exceptionnel mais
vous aviez l'occasion nous semble-t-il à
l'occasion de des Jeux olympiques de
créer les conditions d'un débat beaucoup
plus ouvert d'un débat sur lesquels nous
aurions eu l'occasion de faire avancer
davantage un certain nombre de points au
nom de l'intérêt général et ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas malheureusement et
nous ce nous sortons de l'examen de ce
texte de manière un peu déçue quand même
le groupe socialiste est apparenté a
tenté me semble-t-il à travers les
débats en commission puis indépendant
les débats en séance de faire vivre ce
mot qu'on entend beaucoup depuis le
début de la législature et qui reprend
forcément vigueur depuis quelques jours
le mot de co-construction et qui
malheureusement nous semble-t-il n'est
resté dans bien des cas qu'un mot à
travers l'examen de ce texte
nous n'avons obtenu et pourtant et
pourtant sur des questions qui
relevaient de l'intérêt général et ça a
été dit par mes prédécesseurs bien
souvent du bon sens nous l'avons obtenu
l'adoption de quelques amendements sur
les doigts de la main qui se comptent
sur les doigts de main et même et même
les propositions de rapport ont été
repoussés à l'issue des débats des
demandes légitimes sur lesquelles nous
aurions tous pu tous dû nous réunir ont
été systématiquement rejetés je pense ça
a été évoqué également à cette grande
campagne de prévention et de
communication sur les violences sexistes
qui auraient dû nous réunir à l'occasion
de ce texte à l'occasion de cette
manifestation
et puis surtout la CMP est revenue sur
l'expérimentation ou plutôt est revenu
sur la durée de l'expérimentation il
nous semblait légitime et les débats ici
à l'Assemblée nationale l'avait validé
il nous semblait légitime que
l'expérimentation vidéo surveillance
algorithme se limite à la période des
Jeux Olympiques et même un peu plus loin
nous avions finalement nous nous étions
arrêtés sur la période de décembre 2024
finalement finalement cette
expérimentation durera jusque début
avril 31 mars 2025 ce qui est une
décision
incompréhensible j'ai pas de chance
madame la Présidente parce qu'un seul à
chaque fois que je prends la parole
l'Assemblée nationale se remplit et nous
sommes obligés de faire des pauses de
quelques secondes pour faire en sorte
que la parole puisse se diffuser
vous avez raison un petit silence s'il
vous plaît merci madame la Présidente
décision de repousser l'expérimentation
jusqu'au 31 mars 2025 ce qui est à la
fois incompréhensible et quelque part
très compréhensible parce que ça valide
l'idée que ce texte n'est pas seulement
un texte sur la sécurité et la
sécurisation des Jeux olympiques mais
bien un texte sur la politique de
sécurité du gouvernement et puis madame
la présidente madame la ministre pardon
je reviens sur une question sur laquelle
je me suis permis de vous relancer
plusieurs fois en séance et sur lesquels
nous n'avons jamais obtenu de réponse
précise je reviens sur ce gap énorme
entre les images
issues des scanners corporels à 11 mm
les images qui nous ont été soumises
transférées transmise sur lesquelles on
ne distingue que le VAC silhouette et
sur un certain nombre de documents
officiels y compris l'état d'avancement
des travaux de monsieur le rapporteur
qui disait le scanner corporel est
tellement intrusif que nous demandons à
minima le floutage des visages il y a le
incompréhension au total entre ce qui
figurer dans les travaux du rapporteur
et les images qui nous ont été
transmises il finit
et puis
également
peu de réponses sur ce mariage dangereux
entre vidéosurveillance et algorithme
puisque infini infini nous avons été
renvoyés à quelques slogans de de qui
avec ayant l'objectif de nous rassurer
mais nous renvoyons en permanence un
futur décret dont nous le savons rien et
donc nous ne savons pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui ce que les algorithmes en
question vont identifier vont surveiller
de quelle manière et jusque quand
nous aurons l'occasion de faire parvenir
sur ce fameux article 7 un certain
nombre d'observations au conseil que tu
connais et vous l'aurez deviné madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur que notre vote
sera conforme notre vote finale sera
conforme à celui du vote à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est-à-dire l'abstention
je vous remercie monsieur Vico et nous
allons donc pouvoir procéder au vote
parce scrutin public je vais mettre au
voile le projet de loi tel qu'il est
issu de la commission mixte paritaire le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votant 322 exprimés 301
majorité 151 pour 244 contre 57
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]